but what I'm telling you is ya see there
for three months and I really enjoyed it
or I should fear let me stay at his
place for a little while he's great I
rent him a lot and Kate loves him his
energy he is such a sweet dude and he's
very present yeah and almost every time
I have a conversation with him
I walk away from it with sort of a
little bit more perspective on things we
presently not welcome the staple spinner
yeah that falling out with Kobe Bryant
that make perfect sense right first I
was like what did he do with the Staples
Center
I was like oh I see yes yes no he's a
sweet guy he also had that falling-out
with Kobe Bryant or you know with that
whole deal and so he but that coming
from a positive nihilistic viewpoint and
I talked to him we saw him after that
Kate and I were just walking home and he
was headed downtown I think to do the
seller yeah do the fat black and we
searched stopped him and we talked a
little bit and then I said you know with
the mark Normand stuff mark Normand sort
of spoke about how the people calling in
death threats like why are we not
focusing our anger on those oh that's
really and Ari said yeah I heard that he
said something kind of interesting about
that he said well you know what it's
like it's like you know you just because
because you've had the media go out for
you and I was like yeah and I I do want
to say because I wanted to say this to
him I said and my thing is I didn't
think it was a funny joke I didn't think
it was funny what you didn't he's like
the Nats fine that's fine that's not the
point of it I was like but I don't think
it's wrong if that was your thing and
that's what you do then I don't think
you did anything wrong I think you got
the reaction that you were gonna get by
doing that yeah that's how you learn
whatever it is you don't and you don't
expect that people are not going to
react if you're being a provocateur then
you expect people to feel provoked and
to react in that way which is a form of
art to a lot of people yes and it's sure
harming or is one of my favorite
directors yeah man I thought I saw him
the other day really and I was so afraid
yeah I met a guy
well somebody introduced me to somebody
through I met someone
yeah somebody introduced me to that
person and their name was Harmon
and it really really looked like him but
I was so afraid to ask him God he's so
great gum oh I think it's one of the
great but those films are so viscerally
provocative
yeah and yet always always been
provocative he's always been really
that's his thing and he gets on stage
and he'll talk [ __ ] about Jewish people
and he's Jewish and he had the first
thing I ever saw she was depressed
really almost yeah yeah and the first
thing I saw him in is the amazing race'
so yeah and so that was so long ago but
from the get-go
he was walking around like an Asian
geisha and just being like this ladyship
going back to Africa yeah right so it's
like obviously the guy is into like
jarring types of you really really
pushing pushing pushing department a lot
of people had never seen and you you get
a whole new group never heard of ours
and this is how the first time they hear
about him so that's an easy picking for
a lame / that's a easy picking a hate
you know it's weird like oh I got to
hate somebody today this is the easiest
the lowest hanging fruit right I'm gonna
hate him but I think they probably also
said you know it's just that that was
she be able to say what he wants yeah I
mean for Kate said he should have known
better and I was like he did know just
fine like he knew that and and what I
said to him was it was like so how are
you doing you're fine right and he goes
yeah you know you you realize you get
all this hatred all this stuff it's like
then he close the laptop and you look
crying like birds are chirping I live in
New York it's beautiful outside so the
problem was is that his family and
you'll kind of think about this in the
context of the hate that he got he said
you know the problem was with my family
I realized oh they're taking this
seriously and it's on a national level
and so I had to say to them I'm okay
nobody's gonna kill me I'm being safe so
that's what's really interesting is
nobody really thinks behind all of that
online hatred is a family that is really
scared for their for their son or their
brother yeah I think if the Knicks had
been doing better I think it would add
more support out of New York I'm serious
love that but I do but yeah it was just
look we've all told jokes that have bad
timing
you know what's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us
right now hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two options watch one this one